et on va commenter cette manifestation
avec nos amis temps de rester avec nous
alexis poulain éditorialistes alexis
poulain bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt fonce alors on l'a vu
une manifestation qui manifestement se
déroulait bien
et puis tout d'un coup la situation
s'est véritablement tendu oui alors on
commence à avoir l'habitude
malheureusement de ces manifestations
qui dégénèrent assez rapidement à se
demander si la doctrine du maintien de
l'ordre fonctionne ou s'il ya une
volonté vraiment de laisser pourrir les
manifestations le plus vite possible
pour éviter que qu'elle ne dure et
d'avoir des charges le plus rapidement
possible c'est aussi un problème de
service d'ordre sans doute débordé par
le nombre et un niveau de violence
inédit depuis des mois dans notre pays
assez inquiétant je dois dire et et qui
ne fait que se multiplier chaque week
end sachant que la réponse politique est
inexistante et je pense que le vrai
problème il n'est pas il n'est pas temps
d'en dans ces manifestations à
répétition la rue qui essaye de se faire
entendre mais sur l'absence de réponse
politique sur l'absence de débouchés
démocratique réelle de débat au sein des
assemblées que ce soit le sénat
l'assemblée nationale de manque de
représentation d'un certain nombre de
français et aujourd'hui on arrive à
cette confrontation entre un exécutif
isolé et la rue qui essaye de se faire
entendre
avec finalement à un mât monde
parlementaire balayé par par l'exécutif
finalement qui n'existe pas conseil de
défense décision entre entre décideurs
mais la voie publique n'a pas d'autre
exutoire que malheureusement la rue non
alexiens je sais pas si vous avez accès
à ces images si vous les avez vus mais à
quelques instants on a vu un manifestant
blessé avec un bandage sur la tête vous
l'avez dit une manifestation qui a très
vite dégénéré malheureusement ce n'est
pas la première fois on le rappelle une
manifestation pour dénoncer
à la loi sécurité et globale alexis
pourquoi ce à quoi de quel constat
l'exécutif est il parti pour proposer un
nouveau texte
je crois que depuis de nombreux mois le
projet d' emmanuel macron a de plus en
plus clair c'est à dire qu'il veut
mettre en place une surveillance à
chaque instant de la punition aussi le
plus rapidement possible sous couvert
bien sûr de lois d'exception de lutte
contre le terrorisme de lutte contre les
discours de haine mais au final c'est la
démocratie qu'on verrouille au final
c'est la liberté d'expression qu on
verrouille et au final c'est les moyens
d'expression politique qu on verrouille
c'est le problème de ce centre qui se
veut au cnip autant finalement la droite
la gauche a du bon dans le sens où ça
permet un jeu politique réelle avec des
différences réelles croire
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont des ultra
gauchistes qui sont dans la rue qu'ils
sont énervés etc
c'est faux je crois que c'est la société
française dans son ensemble qui est en
ébullition alors beaucoup ne descendent
pas dans la rue parce que comme vous le
voyez sur ces images il faut mettre un
casque il faut se protéger
maintenant manifestaient devenu un sport
de combat ce n'était pas le cas
auparavant c'est extrêmement inquiétant
ça veut dire que même le droit de
manifester est remis en cause par ce
gouvernement et tout est à
à l'image de ces manifestations chaque
week-end de ses actes d gilet jaune
c'est à dire que comme il n'ya pas de
dialogue comme il n'ya pas de vrais
débats comme il n'ya pas de
représentativité du peuple français dans
son dans sa diversité est bien resté
seulement la rue pour se montrer pour
exister pour finalement faire que
l'exécutif recul dans son agenda de
censure global on doit dire l'article 24
de la loi de sécurité globale sans les
manifestations suite à l' affaire michel
est clair et bien ils seraient passés
avec simplement un tampon de l'assemblée
nationale de ses députés de la majorité
qui ne sont qu'une chambre
d'enregistrement des décisions par
décret ou des décisions de l'exécutif
donc c'est grave ça veut dire que notre
démocratie est profondément miner est
profondément diminué par la pratique du
pouvoir de ce quinquennat et des
quinquennat précédent également on se
rappelle de la loi travail où ce type de
manifestations violentes avaient
commencé à apparaître avec lui de goût
et et après nuit debout
donc c'est devenu une habitude c'est
triste c'est le scandaleux même au pays
des droits de l'homme de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et où on est
capable quand même d'avoir une
démocratie de haute intensité voire
qu'on en arrive à des images qui sont
hebdomadaires et quotidiennes
ça fait mal ça et c'est plus
qu'inquiétant ya bonne humeur ambiante
alex émond téléspectateurs peuvent le
voir les forces de l'ordre ont de
nouveau observé une manifestation qui a
dégénéré
très rapidement ah ben si c'est
malheureux à dire mais ce que c'est la
sphère niche l éclair qui a forcé le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron et sa
majorité à retirer et à réécrire
l'article 24 oui c'est parce que
soudainement
les médias du paysage audiovisuel
français qui pendant des mois avait
évité de parler des violences policières
lors des gilets jaunes ont décidé d'en
faire un point d'honneur et dire oui là
c'est inacceptable mais c'était
inacceptable en 2018 c'est est
inacceptable en 2019 qu'en plus d'une
vingtaine de personnes ont perdu un oeil
ont été mutilées ou plus de 2000
personnes blessées certains ont la
capacité globale seulement à cette
époque-là rappelez-vous emmanuel macron
doctement parler au gilet jaune lors du
grand débat enfin ceux qui étaient
invités pendant qu'on n'a pas le droit
de parler de violences policières dans
une démocratie dans un état de droit et
il a fallu que les médias qui avaient
couvert finalement ces exactions pendant
des moines refusant d'en parler et je
tiens à saluer le travail exceptionnel
de rt france pendant tous ces mois de
mobilisation est encore aujourd'hui
parce que vous êtes sur le terrain parce
que justement vous allez vous fait ce
travail de journalisme qui est essentiel
de montrer comment ça se passe pour ceux
qui ne vont pas en manifestation eh bien
ils ont décidé d'en parler avec la ferme
chez claire's et producteur de musique
qui s'est fait tabasser chez lui mais
c'est trop tard il y a les mots des
malades macro il ya sa volonté d'avoir
la violence voulue réelle politique
imposée par par son gouvernement aux
forces de l'ordre pour mater ce qu'il
entendait comme une révolte celle des
gilets jaunes or on voit bien que cette
révolte n'en finit pas ce n'est pas une
révolte c'est un courant profond en fait
une demande de la société française
d'avoir davantage de démocratie
davantage de représentativité et ça si
il ne l'entend pas s'ils croient que
c'est un bon bout de la sécurité qui va
calmer sa police et encore un grand
débat qui va calmer la population
il a tout faux et on attend et je crois
que en attendant 2022 il y aura besoin
d'un événement majeur autre qu'une
pirouette de communication politique
pour que enfin
soit entendu c'est mobilisation
exceptionnelle qu'on voit depuis des
mois en france quand on voit comment la
manifestation a dégénéré rapidement il
apparaît inévitable que les journalistes
les citoyens du film x ce qui se passe
parce que cet article initialement
devait empêcher au moins dix fois des
les journalistes de filmer les policiers
en exercice lui à tel point d'ailleurs
que le ministre de l'intérieur général
permanent était persuadé que les
journalistes devaient s'inscrire en
préfecture la veille d'une manifestation
pour être autorisée à couvrir les
événements ce qui est à l'encontre de la
liberté de la presse de la loi sur la
liberté de la place de 10 182 la charte
de munich qui est vraiment là pour le
coup mesure totalitaire mais on voit
bien il ya des décrets qui sont passés
pour obliger les journalistes qui
travaillent notamment à couvrir les
évènements ou de faire des reportages
sur la police que les instances est le
dernier mot le droit de censure il ya eu
des décrets aussi sur le fichage sont
passés sur les opinions politiques ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en france est
extrêmement inquiétant et c'était pas
moi seulement qu'il le dit où certains
journalistes c'est les instances de
l'onu c'est les instances du conseil de
l'europe c'est la ligue des droits de
l'homme c'est la défenseure des droits
claire hédon qui sont tous inquiète sur
cette dérive autoritaire et libérale du
gouvernement macro qui voudraient
réduire les libertés et réduire la
liberté de la presse en particulier
alors l'article 24 qu'on revient dessus
mais c'est fou en réalité on le
gouvernement choisit de le réécrire et
de le placer dans la loi sur les
séparatismes d'une autre façon un peu
déguisé même si on entend eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux nous
assurer que les journalistes ne sont pas
en ce qui concerne les discours de haine
la comparution immédiate etc
reste à définir qu'est ce qu'un
journaliste pour le gouvernement si
c'est le gouvernement qui décide qui a
la carte de presse est ce que c'est la
carte de presse qui fait foi
alors on sort qui nous sommes très peu
de journalisme dans ce pays parce que
beaucoup de titres de presse ne paye pas
à la pige ou ne donne pas la carte de
presse et beaucoup de journalistes qui
font ce travail n'ont pas de carte de
presse et je rappelle un pan important
historique philosophique du journalisme
vous n'avez pas besoin de faire une
école nous d'avoir une carte de presse
c'est simplement de pouvoir témoigner de
ce qu'il se passe avec un crayon un
carnet et de montrer vraiment ce qui se
passe dans le journalisme citoyen tout
ce qui a été fait par c'est par ces
anonymes avec leur téléphone portable
avec leur caméra qui ont pu montrer la
réalité de la violence dans les
manifestations du fait des ordres donnés
par la hiérarchie policière
ça c'est du journalisme n'en déplaise
aux journalistes encartés qui qui
préfère parler de journées autorisées
avec la carte
non c'est beaucoup plus large que ça et
ça fait justement la richesse des
démocraties de nos démocraties
occidentales
alexis